biden home alone that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now leave it to joe biden
one year into his presidency and he's
already made himself a lame duck so he's
paddling around by himself
and his pond is now just a muddy puddle
and it's not just republican governors
ignoring him members of his own party
don't want him around either
would you like the president to come and
campaign with you this campaign in texas
is not going to be about joe biden it's
not going to be about donald trump it's
not going to be about anyone from
outside of our state does that mean that
you would prefer that he not come it
means that i'm focused on texas and on
my fellow texans
but the stiffest of stiff arms came
courtesy of stacy abrams who refused to
appear at biden's voting rights speech
in atlanta last month that's her big
issue by the way and we never did find
out what abram's scheduling conflict was
well the truth is biden is human
kryptonite for anyone hoping to win
politically
even the dullest democrat knives in the
drawer know that biden is clueless on
stopping the biggest issue facing us now
which is inflation
now i woke up this morning and listening
to the news
i thought i was living in a 1979 time
warp
the latest inflation number is out and
it shows the biggest jump in prices in
40 years the expectations were already
very high and the reality was worse than
expected i don't see much relief at
least in the next several months
no relief in sight but
wait a second i thought biden was
going to promise us the
d word
i'm going to stay in my message i've
started off saying we have to restore
the dignity and honor of the office and
the soul this country to gain respect in
the country and around the world
but there's no dignity in what his inept
team has done to america
crippling coveted mandates
racist appeals disguised as diversity
and equity
millions of illegals and just for good
measure
skyrocketing living costs
but don't worry because when you're in a
debt hole
you should borrow and spend more right
inflation is up
it's up
and coming from a family the fact is
that
if we're able to do the things i'm
talking about here
it'll bring down the cost for average
families
bring down the cost for average families
in my build back better legislation we
can do that there's a lot we can do to
give families extra breathing room
we can do this
absurd on its face biden's plan
to borrow or print and then spend more
money money that we don't have will only
stoke more inflation
now this is all very obvious it's kind
of econ 101
which i think joe's top advisors
apparently just slept through
we have historically strong economic
growth in january we now see that real
wages after adjusting for inflation were
up there is some light in this report
under the hood i expect inflation to
come down significantly in 2022.
consider the source
they're the same group who last year
predicted only short-term inflation
remember that
now if biden had really wanted to help
the economy
he would have immediately ended all
coveted mandates he would have opened
everything up
and he would have told the nation
it's time he'll do it like this right
it's time to go back to work
including the federal government
got to go back to work but he's not
going to say that instead he likes to
pull what we call the biden and switch
i'm asking the american people to mask
up for the first hundred days
hundred days of masking
right well if you were watching the
angle you would have known that when
biden said a hundred
days of masking he really meant a
hundred years
of masking
soon americans were on to his little
game though
they saw that florida and south dakota
which went virtually masculist the
entire pandemic
were no worse off than universally mass
new york and illinois in fact
floridians and south dakotans
they even seemed happier a lot happier
than the mandate states
thus with the midterms around the corner
it's not surprising that state mask
mandates are dropping faster than
lizzo's clothes
they can't afford to wait until biden
sees the light on these coven mandates
especially when this woman runs the cdc
now our cdc guidance has not changed
continue to recommend universal masking
in our schools
although infuriating this defiance is a
huge gift to republicans
just look at biden's approval ratings a
new cnn poll puts biden's overall
approval at 41
58 disapprove
now of those who disapprove prove 56
percent
said they approve of
nothing i repeat nothing that biden has
done while in office
biden's fast and dramatic slide downward
explains why mcconnell is now totally
comfortable just telling republican
governors to ignore altogether the biden
administration's guidance on how to
spend that infrastructure money they're
gonna get
in other words ditch the bike lanes fix
the bridges
and how happy are mansion and cinema
that they didn't buckle on that voting
rights bill now
pelosi's media bullies turned up the
pressure campaign on them but the
senators resisted and then they were
trashed by the left they didn't care but
they obviously made the right call
as for the other senators who bill
themselves as reasonable moderates but
who've never spoken out
they're desperately trying to play
catch-up now
the national democratic brand in in in i
think in rural america general is toxic
and it's because
quite frankly we don't show up we're not
willing to go places we're not wanted
and answer questions i honestly don't
think the democratic party can be a
majority party unless we start appealing
to middle america a lot more
yeah thank john it's a little late
where were you last spring last summer
and last fall
does he think montanans are stupid
they know a phony when they see one they
tuned out biden and they're going to
tune out tester as well
but the abandonment of biden isn't just
happening on the home front of course
our allies are also moving on from him
just recently
french president emmanuel macron
decided to bypass the bumbling biden
altogether
and then go on to have his own meeting
with vladimir putin to defuse the
ukraine situation
that's obvious what happened here
european leaders saw biden as a problem
not a solution kind of a bull in a china
shop abiding in a china shop so they
felt that they had to rush in to
de-escalate
how embarrassing for america getting
briefed
and ordered around by the french
but not any more embarrassing than
america being left in the dust by the
chinese
under biden our overall trade deficit
ballooned to an all-time high this is
shocking
859
billion dollars that's a 27 percent
increase from the year before
president biden might not know how to
make americans happy but the chinese
they got to love him because the trade
deficit with china
grew
14.5
for the full year
to
355 billion dollars reversing the
decline that followed then president
donald trump's policies aimed at
reducing the deficit with tariffs and
purchase targets by the way biden's team
wants to get rid of all the tariffs too
this is as despicable as it is as
heartbreaking
now all because we have a president that
no one trusts or respects to stand up
for the average american president xi
knows that biden is easily rolled or
just easily ignored altogether
ditto with his military men secretary
austin and general milley for whom
i don't think
china or probably putin have much
respect for to them
woke is a joke in the u.s military sadly
under this leadership great men and
women are pushed to go woke
so democrats they made a terrible choice
in joe biden
his hologram campaign has become a
hologram presidency
and when he does appear in public i put
a peer in quotes
he has no presence he has no credibility
and he has little influence
now given all this maybe he should just
stay home alone for the next three years
and let nancy run things for a while
oh on second thought
and that's the angle